so that was kind of an anti-climax Queen
takes Knight the last episode before the
winter break for Gotham episode 11 of
the season and I don't love it
and I probably would like it more if it
wasn't this sort of the sort of mini
finale kind of episode because it felt
really predictable almost everything
that happened felt like a very logical
extension of stuff we already knew was
going on and the few surprises that it
had it all blew in the first half of the
episode so I mean I'll start out with
some positives it started out really
well the Penguins siding with carmine
was cool I liked that the fact that
Carmine's death well first of all
Carmine's death improv it was inevitable
they set up he was dying anyway and I
mean carmine Falcone part of his role in
the Batman mythos is to die and leave a
power vacuum so we always knew he was
gonna die but the timing work that was a
little bit of a surprise I really liked
how that affected Victor Zsasz and how
he was but Victor has been amazing this
season I just I love him so much I love
his performance he's so awesome
so all that worked well the stuff was
Sophia if you know anything about Sofia
in the comics not a lot of it as a huge
surprise that said I did like the
shout-out to her original depiction in
the comics once she got the neck brace
kind of wish they kept her in it for a
little longer before having her taken
off from revealing she didn't need it I
feel like to set that up and like get
rid of it in one episode felt wasteful
that's sad I still appreciate the nod
but the thing is aside from that
everything like I said either feels like
an incredibly logical extension of what
have been going on in the last couple of
episodes or you know just stuff that
feels repetitive so like for example
once we were done with Carmine's funeral
and once you know the penguin have been
basically ousted from power okay so we
get a really in-depth look of
how manipulative Sophia is that's kind
of interesting and I did like earlier on
when she's come friend of your father
that she kind of had the spoiled brat
moment and it does a nice thing to sort
of undercut how in control she tries to
be to have to have her happy moments
like but I deserve this and like that
felt that was nice because characters
who feel like they're in too much
control aggravate me and even though you
could argue that was part of her plan I
feel like that moment with her and her
father was very genuine and she wanted
him to give her acknowledgement that
that she could do this and if he had she
probably would have called off the hit
but so all that stuff plays out but then
what happens later on in that so Tabitha
kidnaps and beats up Grundy trying to
bring butch back it's not a huge shock
because they'd already seeded the idea
that butch is still somehow in there and
that he was gonna recognize her so you
figured this was gonna play out at one
point okay none of that is a huge
surprise we're seeing Edie continue to
struggle with the Riddler a little bit
we saw that last episode so again a
decent moment but not a huge surprise
Bruce firing young Bruce and Alfred
coming to blows and Bruce eventually
firing Alfred who didn't see that coming
as part of his downward decline and that
also feels really inevitable like the
few things that didn't feel like really
super obvious continuations of the last
couple of episodes were you know maybe
the thing would professor pig and then
Gordon you know having to cover up for
that but I also don't like those things
the here's my issue with professor pig
it's not inherently a bad reveal that
you know he was in cahoots with Sophia
the problem is as far as I'm concerned
that makes him less interesting as a
character the version of pig that we got
prior to this reveal was way more
interesting than this now he went from
this psychotic with a flourish in a
bizarre moral code to just a hired
killer who pretended to have those
interesting aspects that's disappointing
and I feel like that undermines how much
fun Knight had with the character up to
this point so I didn't like that and
then as far as Jim's whole thing with
covering up the fact that Sophia killed
him
and now he's compromised it's not a bad
story arc but it feels incredibly
redundant because didn't we basically do
this two seasons ago when he killed a
galavant I mean it feels very much the
same was like bring him down low and you
know dirty him up we dirtied him up
already now we're cycling through this
version of the same arc for him again
and I don't like that because it just it
feels repetitive it feels like haven't
we been here before so I'm not a big fan
of that The Joker reveal at the very end
hinting that he's gonna somehow team up
with it well I say joke right so just
call him Jerome because the the makers
are still being a little bit squirrely
as to whether he is the Joker or just a
precursor to the Joker that we know so I
shouldn't call him that so Jerome Jerome
Ian hinting that he's got a team-up with
the penguin not a decent set up no not a
not a bad set up note to end on but
everything else up to that point was
just I was just kind of okay and again
none of it pad there's nothing wrong
with it but to have it feel like you
know look at this situation we're
leaving you in when most of it was stuff
I would have called before just feels
anticlimactic this doesn't feel like a
mid-season finale this feels like the
episode before a mid-season finale if
I'm being honest it moves the cogs that
were already placed forward a little bit
but doesn't really feel like it builds
too much and if this was the episode
before our mid-season finale I'd
probably be fine with it maybe I
wouldn't love it but it just seems like
a weak note to sort of go into the
hiatus on so yeah didn't love it which
is disappointing because I've been
pretty stoked for most of this season
especially the last few episodes so I
don't love the fact that I didn't like
it all that much but hey it happens so
those are my thoughts on Queen takes
Knight the latest episode of Gotham did
you see it what did you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it don't forget to Like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
council of geeks give a listen to the
council of geeks podcast that's
available on Apple podcast and stitcher
radio I'm also one half of the punch
like a girl podcast that is a
presentation of the fire and water
Cass Network firing water Podcast comm
links for all this stuff is down below
and until next time this council is
adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]